the search continues for a 22 year old
Texas National Guard soldier who
vanished in the Rio Grande while trying
to help two migrants who appeared to be
drowning as they illegally crossed the
river from Mexico into the United States
the Texas Rangers have determined that
the two migrants were trafficking
illicit narcotics into America and they
are now in custody of border patrol
joining me right now is the man who has
taken manners into his own hands Texas
governor Greg Abbott Governor it's good
to see you this morning thanks very much
for being here
thank you Maria great to be back
first is your
sister is the graduation Forest
forest and border
sure well listen first we we keep the
soldier in our prayers we continue to
search for them there's no new
additional information to be issued by
the Texas Military Department today
other than the fact that obviously what
has happened is a tragedy it shows how
dangerous it is on the border it shows
heroism uh by the member of the Texas
National Guard who was trying to save
lives fortunately for the the people
he's trying to say the lives of they
turn out to be drug traffickers and they
were both arrested but our goal right
now is to locate this missing soldier
with the Texas Military Department and
hopefully it will lead to a safe outcome
but we have no information uh that we
can add to what's going on right now
about that particular Soldier we do have
information about what's going on on the
board because as you know it's a total
disaster a creative but not only by
President Biden in his administration
but by the Democrats across the board
and we have a president United States
has who has not negotiated with a
president to Mexico so I as governor of
Texas have taken matters into my own
hands and I've negotiated Landmark
historic deals with the governors of
Mexican states that are adjacent to
Texas where these Mexican states are
still are going to step up and they are
going to start securing the border and
that's on top of things that Texas has
done that's never been done before in
the history of America such as Texas
building its own border wall Texas
laying down miles of razor wire to
prevent people from coming across the
border creating a boat blockades and I
will tell you this something else has
never happened before and that is the
Texas National Guard they have turned
back more than 15 000 people who
attempted to come across the border
illegally so Texas is doing everything
we possibly can to contain a completely
out of control border situation uh
that's the worst that I've ever seen it
Governor uh tell me about the illicit
drugs coming across as well 100
000 overdosed deaths in America because
largely due to fentanyl coming across
the border what can you tell us about
that
this is a a national disaster it could
be a catastrophe because of what could
happen in the country uh people need to
understand that there's been enough
fentanyl seized to kill every man woman
and child in the United States of
America we could lose our entire
population because this there was a
report a month ago in the Houston
Chronicle talking about how in Harris
County Texas uh there's one person who
dies every single day because of these
fentanyl overdoses this fentanyl mostly
either the fentanyl itself or the
components of it come from China to
Mexico then comes across the border and
then is spread throughout the entire
country by Cartel activity and the byte
Administration is allowing this to
happen by Biden and his administration's
refusal to step up and do anything about
it
I don't understand this decision to lift
title 42 Governor I mean the president
is pushing a mask mandate on planes
continuing to tell us that we are still
in an emergency situation and yet he is
lifting title 42 that is expected to go
away on May 23rd what are you expecting
once that is lifted
so that's one month from yesterday when
all this would happen and not only do
you not understand it most members of
Congress and the United States Senate
including Democrats don't understand and
I can tell you most Americans don't
understand and so no one knows what
Biden is trying to do by this but what
we all know is if he lives title 42 it
will be catastrophic for the United
States of America because look only at
what his own Department of Homeland
Security has stated and that is to
expect with the lifting of title 42
about 18 000 people coming across the
border per day do the math on that and
you will find it means that more than 6
million people will be coming across the
border a year and and about half of
those would be in the state of Texas
that we would have coming across the
border in one year more people than are
residents of our largest city in Texas
which is Houston we would be adding more
than one Houston a year there's no way
the state of Texas can assimilate those
people uh and there's no way the United
States can assimilate that number of
people and so what Joe Biden is doing is
far more than Reckless it's the most
disastrous thing to the United States of
America anybody's ever witnessed In Our
Lifetime
this is just extraordinary in fact Nikki
Haley had tweeted out a graphic of the
actual number of people coming across
and that it is exceeding major cities uh
some states in terms of the amount of
people coming in illegally you have
taken matters into your own hands tell
me how it's going and specifically what
you're doing here is the graphic I'm
referring to in terms of the illegal
migrants let in under Biden it is
exceeding the population of Miami
Atlanta Seattle San Francisco Austin
it's absolutely extraordinary how are
these bus trips going you are dropping
these migrants off in Washington and
you're getting blowback uh what are they
doing when they get to Washington
well first let me tell you why we're
doing this I was visiting with local
leaders along the border uh in towns
like Del Rio Uvalde and other
communities where the byte
Administration they were dropping off
migrants in these communities and there
was no way for these small towns to be
able to deal with or or handle uh the
the this overload of I was just being
dumped into these local communities and
they were asking for help and they were
talking about themselves now bussing
these migrants up to San Antonio I said
I got a better idea uh let's just bust
them all the way to Washington D.C and
so we continue to bust these migrants up
to Washington D.C there is a a positive
potential outcome in the short term for
this and that is what we've found is
that the border patrol is no longer
dropping these migrants off in these
communities that have previously been
dropped off in because they're
overloaded but this is I think in
response to a dictate from the Bible
Administration to stop in fact aiding
Governor Abbott and his effect of
bussing people to Washington D.C by
reducing the number of people available
to do so that said Maria uh with the
with the sheer number of people coming
across the border beginning uh in a
month we will continue uh these bus
routes to Washington D.C and I will tell
you as soon as I announce that our
phones started ringing off the hook
about people wanting to help and I want
to tell Americans uh where you can go to
help pay for a bus trip for migrants to
go to Washington DC and make the buy
Administration deal with it in person go
to
borderbus.texas.gov that's
borderbus.texas.gov you can contribute
to us uh busing those migrants to
Washington DC and make the by
demonstration deal with it themselves
uh Governor there are reports that this
Administration is completely blowing off
uh court orders to reinstate remain in
Mexico can you confirm
oh yes listen they're blowing off
there's a court order that the Texas
Attorney General obtained uh requiring
the remaining Mexico policy and and the
by Administration is completely ignored
it uh you may know that it's coming up
for a supreme court hearing this coming
week uh and surely the Supreme Court
will rule in our favor hopefully but no
one is holding Biden accountable for his
Reckless decision to ignore all of these
policies that previously had led to the
lowest number of illegal Crossings uh in
decades it's time for the by
Administration to start following the
laws passed by Congress
Governor will be watching and we'll
certainly keep a spotlight on it thanks
very much for your time this morning we
so appreciate it Texas governor Greg
Abbott joining us exclusively